[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen in allen Norbert Lehmann ist
auch dabei für den Sport
und das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
Polen erhöht den Druck für die Lieferung
von Leopard Kampfpanzern an die Ukraine
will Warschau die Zustimmung
Deutschlands beantragen
aufatmen in den Krankenhäusern vor allem
auf den Intensivstationen geht die Zahl
der corona-kranken zurück
und mit Vollgas ins WM-Viertelfinale
Deutschlands Handballer spielen am Abend
gegen Norwegen um den Gruppensieg
[Musik]
wer liefert der Ukraine die so dringend
geforderten Kampfpanzer in diese Frage
kam heute Bewegung polen will bei der
Bundesregierung offiziell um eine
Genehmigung bitten um Leopard 2 Panzer
aus eigenen Beständen in die Ukraine zu
schicken
Polen gehört zu einem der NATO-Länder
mit großem Bestand an Leopard zwei
Panzern nach eigenen Angaben hat das
polnische Militär 249 davon in
unterschiedlichen Ausführungen 14 soll
die Ukraine bekommen aus Warschau
Natalie Steger
noch sind sie auf polnischem Boden
Leopard Panzer der polnischen Armee 14
will Warschau dringend in die Ukraine
schicken dafür braucht es von
Deutschland als Herstellerland die
Zustimmung polen will nicht mehr warten
selbst wenn wir die Erlaubnis nicht
bekommen würden werden wir trotzdem
unsere Panzer an die Ukraine übergeben
zusammen mit anderen dann innerhalb
einer kleinen Koalition auch wenn
Deutschland nicht dabei wäre
soll heißen keinerlei Eingang aber zur
Not an Deutschland vorbei auch polnische
Militärexperten dringen
es liegt in unserem Sicherheitsinteresse
ich hoffe die deutschen verstehen dass
die Ukraine für uns Polen und die
Deutschen gegen Russland kämpfen das
nicht die Absicht hat in der Ukraine
Halt zu machen
die deutsche Zurückhaltung sorgt seit
Tagen für Unverständnis in Polen eine
Schande sei es ist etwa zu lesen und die
deutsche Blockade käme Putin entgegen
die deutsch-russischen Kontakte scheinen
noch aktiv zu sein deswegen werden die
Deutschen die Übergabe schwerer Waffen
an die Ukraine so stark wie möglich
blockieren sie sollen die Ausrüstung
übergeben sie sind doch nicht an der
Frontlinie
Polens nationalkonservative Regierung
forciert das Thema auch aus
innenpolitischen Gründen denn mit keinem
anderen lässt sich parteiübergreifend
derart Punkten und im Herbst sind
Parlamentswahlen in Polen fast geht da
unter das Deutschland zwei Patriot
flugabwehrraketenstaffeln heute Richtung
Südosten Polens geschickt hat zum Schutz
der nato-ostflanke doch Warschau will
mehr Leopard Panzer für die Ukraine
14 Leoparden aus Polen werden der
Ukraine nicht reichen und so steigt der
internationale Druck auf Deutschland
immer weiter bislang ohne Erfolg der
Bundeskanzler hält sich nach wie vor die
Entscheidung offen und auch zur
polnischen bitte hatte sich bislang
nicht geäußert aus Berlin Andreas
die Ukraine und die Leopard Panzer nach
dem Polen Tatsachen schaffen will geht
es im Kanzleramt um die Frage liefern Ja
oder Nein noch sperrt sich Olaf Scholz
all dem Drängen seinen Sprecher lässt
der verkünden dass seine offizielle
Anfrage bislang noch gar nicht gestellt
worden sein
bisher gibt es eine Ankündigung das ist
ja noch keine Anfrage sagen wir wollen
das tun sondern da geht es um die
genaueren Spezifikation das muss man
sich dann angucken und prüfen auch in
Brüssel wird geprüft und beraten gestern
hatte die Außenministerin erklärt
Deutschland werde eine leopardlieferung
nicht im Wege stehen wenn man gefragt
wird heute hört sich das anders an das
Wort Panzer kommt nicht mehr vor
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir als
internationale Partner gemeinsam
vorgehen bei der Unterstützung und dem
Recht auf Selbstverteidigung der Ukraine
vielen Dank sagt und in schwindet der
Koalitionspartner von der FDP ist in der
kausal Leopard heute auch auffallen
zurückhaltend entscheiden ist dass wir
am Ende des Tages gemeinsame Lösungen
hin bekommen und bei so einer zentralen
Frage bin ich davon überzeugt dass wir
das auch hinbekommen und die SPD die
stellt heute Konzept für eine künftige
Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik vor das
Verhältnis zu Russland definieren die
Sozialdemokraten darin neu
es gilt jetzt Sicherheit in Europa vor
Russland zu organisieren das ist ein
Bruch auch mit dem was wir bisher als
SPD formuliert hatten wo es immer darum
ging Sicherheit und Stabilität in Europa
mit Russland zu organisieren ob dazu
auch die Lieferung von
leopard-kampfpanzern an die Ukraine
gehört darauf heute keine Antwort diese
Frage hält weiter das politische Berlin
in Atem und die Bundesregierung unter
Druck
fragen wir nach in Brüssel wo heute die
EU-Außenminister tagten Florian Neuhann
wie ist das steht Deutschland mit seiner
Zurückhaltung bei der Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern tatsächlich alleine da das
wirkt hier auf der Brüsseler Bühne
erstmal so auch heute waren die
Befürworter dieser Lieferungen vor allem
aus dem Baltikum und Polen sehr
lautstark unterwegs und dann gibt es
tatsächlich keine Regierung kein Land
dass der deutschen Bundesregierung
offensiv in der skeptischen Haltung zur
Seite springen würde aber wenn man dann
die nächste und ja vielleicht
entscheidende Frage stellt nämlich
welches Land tatsächlich bereit wäre aus
den eigenen Beständen Leopard Panzer in
die Ukraine zu liefern er dann schrumpft
die Liste dieser Befürworter doch
ziemlich deutlich bestes Beispiel auf
das auch Berlin immer wieder verweist
ist etwas Spanien das im letzten Sommer
noch angeboten hatte Leopard Panzer zu
liefern das aber wieder zurückgezogen
hat weil die Panzer einfach nicht
einsatzfähig sein und ähnlich so hört
man argumentiert auch manchmal anderes
Land hier in Brüssel wird immer wieder
davon gesprochen dass man eigentlich
nicht ein Dutzend sondern 300 Panzer
bräuchte um auf dem Schlachtfeld einen
Unterschied zu machen ja und von dieser
Zahl sind die Befürworter von
Panzerlieferungen noch ziemlich weit
entfernt danke für diese Einschätzung
aus Brüssel florian-
in der Ukraine erschüttern die Regierung
zwei mögliche korruptions-skandale das
Verteidigungsministerium soll
überteuerte Lebensmittel eingekauft
haben und ein Vizeminister für die
Entwicklung von Gemeinden wurde wegen
Bestechung festgenommen
Präsident silensky kündigte ein
entschlossenes Vorgehen an bei Razzien
beschlagnahmten die Behörden umgerechnet
knapp 60.000 Euro laut transparent sie
international ist die Ukraine eines der
korruptesten Länder Europas
Katrin Eigendorf ist im Moment in Harke
Katrin welche Rolle spielt Korruption in
diesem Krieg
nun der Krieg hat natürlich an der
Tatsache dass die Strukturen hier extrem
korrupt sind nicht wirklich etwas
geändert und so erschüttert dieser
Skandal natürlich vor allem im Moment
das Vertrauen denn es handelt sich ja um
Bereiche die wir im Wesentlichen auch
von westlicher Unterstützung abhängig
sind nämlich Infrastruktur und Militär
aber man muss hier natürlich
unterscheiden auf der einen Seite hat es
hier wirklich eine Untersuchung gegeben
die dazu führte dass der Vizeminister
zurücktreten abtreten musste auf der
anderen Seite was das
Verteidigungsministerium betrifft sind
die Untersuchungen noch gar nicht
abgeschlossen und der
Verteidigungsminister Risiko hatte heute
selbst klar gemacht dass er diese
Vorwürfe für absolut haltlos hält sieht
darin sogar im Prinzip eine Kampagne um
das Verteidigungsministerium in dieser
Situation zu schwächen das Parlament hat
heute darüber getagt und es ist klar und
der Präsident selber hat das auch noch
mal klar gemacht dass diese Vorwürfe
rückhaltlos aufgeklärt werden müssen
das heißt Korruption immer noch ein
großes Problem in der Ukraine aber was
man positiv natürlich auch sehen muss
das ist dem Land gelingt trotz dieser
angespannten und schwierigen Lage in der
sich seit elf Monaten befindet immerhin
diese Vorwürfe zu untersuchen und
anscheinend auch aufzuklären denn es hat
ja schon Rücktritte gegeben und was den
zweiten Fall angeht müssen wir einfach
abwarten danke schön Katrin Eickendorf
zurück nach Deutschland eine beruhigende
Meldung kommt von den zuletzt stark
belasteten Intensivstationen dort
entspannt sich die Lage der Grund es
gibt viel weniger corona-patienten auch
die Zahl der Neuaufnahmen sinkt täglich
schauen wir auf die letzten 12 Monate
mussten vor einem Jahr noch knapp 2500
Patienten intensiv medizinisch behandelt
werden sind es aktuell noch 670 aus
München Sibylle Basler
die Intensivstation 4 der München
Uniklinik Großhadern aktuell behandeln
Michael irlbeck und sein Team ihr sechs
schwerkranke covid-patienten womit ist
nach wie vor da es beschäftigt uns immer
noch aber es ist auf ein gewisses Maß
einer Normalität zurückgekehrt rund 300
Patienten haben sie hier in den letzten
Jahren versorgt ständig am Limit doch
seit Januar gehen die Zahlen zurück
bundesweit wir hatten Anfang des Jahres
ja über 1500
Intensivpatienten mit kobit 19 die wir
auf unseren Intensivstationen in
Deutschland behandeln mussten stand
heute sind wir unter 700 genau 670 also
ein deutlicher Rückgang was uns sehr
optimistisch stimmt denn weniger
Krankheitsfälle insgesamt bedeuten auch
weniger Ausfälle beim Klinikpersonal und
somit eine Verbesserung der personellen
Situation die Lage scheint sich zu
entspannen gerade auch für nicht
Patienten wir können jetzt Operation die
wir im Dezember nicht machen konnten
nachholen das ist ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt und diese Patientenzahlen gehen
auch hoch also wir atmen durch und es
wird besser
durchatmen ja aber die Pandemie sei
nicht vorbei so
michig gerade für vulnerable Patienten
wie diesen Mann Anfang 60 der vor vier
Jahren lungentransplantiert wurde und es
war sehr knapp dass es überlebt auch
infektiologe Clemens wendner warnt davor
Corona jetzt auf die leichte Schulter zu
nehmen das Infektionsgeschehen ist
entschleunigt das kann man klar sagen
aber ich glaube wir müssen noch ein
bisschen wachsam sein neue Varianten ist
das Stichwort die müssen sehr genau
beobachtet werden denn wann die Pandemie
vorbei ist das kannst du im jetzigen
Zeitpunkt niemand sagen
der Chef der Kassenärztlichen
Bundesvereinigung Gassen er geht davon
aus dass die pandemische Lage vorbei ist
und fordert ein Ende der maskenpflicht
in Arztpraxen bundesweit und auch der
deutsche Hausärzteverband hat sich heute
für ein Ende der maskenpflicht in Praxen
ausgesprochen
Stromausfälle herbeiführen
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach entführen
letztlich Zustände wie im Bürgerkrieg
dazu nutzen die Demokratie zu stürzen
all das planten laut Bundesanwaltschaft
vier Männer und eine Frau gegen die
jetzt offiziell Anklage erhoben wurde
die Beschuldigten sitzen seit Monaten in
Untersuchungshaft vorgeworfen wird Ihnen
die Vorbereitung eines
hochverräterischen Unternehmens gegen
den Bund
seit Jahren streitet Deutschland über
ein Tempolimit nun zeigt eine Studie es
könnte das Klima stärker schützen als
gedacht ein Limit von 120 km/h auf
Autobahnen würde laut Umweltbundesamt
pro Jahr 6,7 Millionen Tonnen CO2
einsparen bisher war die Behörde von
weniger als der Hälfte ausgegangen
Verkehrsminister Wissing FDP hatte
argumentiert dass ein Tempolimit kaum
Emissionen einsparen würde
und auch auf dem Wasser wird Klimaschutz
wichtiger die überwiegend mit Schweröl
angetriebenen Schiffsmotoren sollen
sauberer werden im Jahr 2018 hat der
Internationale Schiffsverkehr mehr als
1000 Millionen Tonnen CO2 ausgestoßen
das entspricht 2,9% aller Emissionen
weltweit zum Vergleich Deutschlands
gesamt CO2-Ausstoß lag bei rund 860
Millionen Tonnen globaler Anteil etwa
2%, Anja kapinos
ein rotierender Zylinder der Windkraft
nutzt wie ein Segel auf einem
Frachtschiff oder dieser Fähre hier
kombiniert mit einem Hybridmotor das
spart Kraftstoff und CO2 an der
Universität Rostock forscht ein Team von
Ingenieuren daran wie Schiffsmotoren
vollkommen klimaneutral werden können
sie entwickeln völlig neue Antriebe
testen aber auch wie herkömmliche
Verbrennungsmotoren etwa mit Wasserstoff
oder Ammoniak betrieben werden können
Lösungen die wir als retrofit bezeichnen
die ist also auch ermöglichen bestehende
Schiffe die heute noch mit fossilen
kraftstoffverfahren zukünftig umzurüsten
auf erneuerbare Kraftstoffe denn Schiffe
haben eine sehr sehr lange Lebensdauer
und wenn wir nur auf die Erneuerung der
Flotte warten dann werden wir definitiv
zu langsam sein es gibt viel aufzuholen
denn im globalen Markt mit hohem
Preisdruck fehlen Anreize und strenge
Vorschriften auf moderne Techniken
umzurüsten wir kommen ja in der globalen
Schifffahrt vom Schweröl das ist
sozusagen die billigste Form der Energie
die überhaupt kriegen können und da
jetzt umzustellen auf erneuerbare
Kraftstoffe die natürlich viel viel
teurer sind ist ein wirklich eine große
Herausforderung mit Schweröl wird immer
noch auf den Weltmeeren gefahren was
allein bei den schwefel-emissionen bis
zu 500 Fach dreckiger ist als Auto
Diesel die deutschen Räder haben sich
verpflichtet bis 2050 klimaneutral zu
werden ein Großteil der Bestellungen bei
Schiffs Neubauten machen weltweit aber
immer noch konventionelle Antriebe aus
nachdem Angriff in einem Nachtclub bei
Los Angeles hat die Polizei den
mutmaßlichen Täter tod aufgefunden nach
einer Verfolgungsjagd mit der Polizei
erschoss sich der 72-Jährige asiatischer
Herkunft in seinem Wagen am Samstagabend
hatte der Mann bei einer Feier zum
chinesischen Neujahrsfest zehn Menschen
erschossen und zehn zum Teil schwer
verletzt sein Motiv ist völlig unklar
das ist Margot Friedländer 101 Jahre alt
Berlinerin Jüdin und Menschenfreundin
obwohl ihre ganze Familie im KZ
umgebracht wurde Margot Friedländer
selbst überlebte emigrierte nach New
York und wohnt jetzt wieder in ihrer
Heimatstadt Berlin unermüdlich erzählt
sie ihre Geschichte am liebsten in
Schulen dafür bekam sie jetzt eine der
höchsten Auszeichnungen der
Bundesrepublik henriet
das Bundesverdienstkreuz erster Klasse
für die 101-Jährige Margot Friedländer
verliehen von der regierenden
Bürgermeisterin von Berlin Berlin das
ist Margot Friedländers Geburtsstadt was
war und das dürfen nie wieder geschehen
sagt sie und fragt wem soll ich danken
meiner Mutter euch meinen Freunden sag
seit Mensch wenn ihr Menschen seid könnt
ihr keine antisemite Zeit ihr müsst
Menschen respektieren
respektiert Menschen wir sind alle
gleich
1921 wird Margot Friedländer geboren sie
ist Jüdin träumt davon Modezeichnerin zu
werden
1943 werden ihr Bruder Ralf und die
Mutter verhaftet und im KZ Auschwitz
ermordet sie selbst überlebt das KZ
Theresienstadt nach der Befreiung geht
sie mit ihrem Mann nach Amerika lebt ein
glückliches Leben sie ist 88 Jahre alt
als sie zurück nach Berlin zieht ins
Land der Täter sie ich bin
zurückgekommen um euch die Hand zu
reichen sie geht in Schulen als
Zeitzeugen sie mahnt klärt auf legt
Zeugnis ab im Berliner Rathaus enthüllen
sie heute eine Büste für die
Ehrenbürgerin Berlins Margot friedländer
hier bin ich geboren
hier will sterben
die Welt
ist erstaunlich
was für ein Leben
was für ein Leben Margot friedländer
ja Mensch Handball WM jetzt in einer
Stunde ist es soweit Deutschland gegen
Norwegen Mannschaften haben sich zwar
schon für die Ko-Runde qualifiziert und
zwar vorzeitig dennoch es geht um den
Gruppensieg und der entscheidet ob das
DHB-Team am Mittwoch im Viertelfinale
auf Spanien oder auf Rekordweltmeister
Frankreich trifft
beim DHB wird fleißig gepackt schon vor
dem Anpfiff heute Abend gegen Norwegen
in Kattowitz das Ergebnis eigentlich
egal beide Teams bereits fürs
Viertelfinale qualifiziert aber keine
Lust da drauf unsere Leistungsgruppe
dann abflachen zu lassen
Viertelfinale auf Spanien der Verlierer
auf Frankreich für Frankreichs Trainer
GMG kein Unterschied das wird da Kämpfe
egal wer da vor uns steht Konzentration
jetzt aber erst einmal auf das
Hauptrundenspiel gegen Norwegen den WM 2
von 2019
ja noch ein deutsches Team steht in
einem WM-Viertelfinale nämlich dass der
Hocke Männer bei der Weltmeisterschaft
in Indien durch den souveränen 5:17
gegen Frankreich
es soll die perfekte Hockey Woche werden
Deutschland den dunklen Trikots
problemlos auftrumpfend gegen Frankreich
das 14
Minute vier Tore innerhalb von 10
Minuten nach dem 1 zu 4 der Franzosen
der Endstand in der 59 Minute das 5 zu 1
im Viertelfinale wartet England auf das
deutsche unbesiegte Team weiterhin mit
dem Traum nach 2022 und 2016
Traumstadt für Annalena Forster bei der
para Ski-WM in spanischen eSport
immonoshi-fahrerin gewann in der
sitzenden Klasse mit fast drei Sekunden
Vorsprung den Super G das ist insgesamt
ihr sechstes Gold bei einer WM für
Deutschlands para Sportlerin des Jahres
zum zweiten Sonntagsspiel in der
Fußball-Bundesliga Leverkusen Sieg gegen
Gladbach die Bayer elf lange Zeit
spielbeherrscht und hier das 3:0 durch
Ernährung in der 67 Minute erst in den
letzten 10 Minuten die borussia-anzug
zwei Mal Stindl der Anschlusstreffer
aber erst in der Nachspielzeit und am
Ende gewinnt Leverkusen mit 3 zu 2 der 4
Sieg in Serie
alle Höhepunkte alle Tore des Spieltags
zu sehen war heute de und in der heute
App Dankeschön bitteschön rote Karten
gibt es im Fußball immer wieder aber die
weiße Karte für Fairplay die gab's noch
nie bis jetzt bei einem Pokalspiel in
Portugal ging es einer Ersatzspielerin
schlecht die Mannschaftsärzte beider
Teams eilten ihr zur Hilfe dafür gab es
von der Schiedsrichterin
spontan die weiße Karte und die Fans
schauten erst ein wenig verdutzt und
freut sich dann
ruhiges Winterwetter begleitet uns die
nächsten Tage wann sich das ändert
erfahren Sie gleich von Katja horneffer
Christian Sievers freut sich auf Sie im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn und
hier übernimmt morgen metri Siren danke
für Ihr Interesse einen schönen Abend
noch und auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend eine Hochnebel Decke hat
sich über Deutschland ausgebreitet die
gab aber hin und wieder auch mal den
Blick auf die Sonne frei zum Beispiel am
Main oder auch in Bayern ja es liegt ja
eine ganze Menge Schnee in Deutschland
auch im Flachland zum Teil etliche
Zentimeter noch mehr natürlich in den
Gipfel lagen jetzt in der Nacht kommt
kein neuer Schnee mehr dazu es bildet
sich zum Teil Nebel oder dunsen das kann
auch glatt sein auf dem Straßen denn die
Temperaturen sinken auch Werte zwischen
ein und -6 Grad am Alpen Rand wird es
aber am kältesten morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen in den östlichen
Mittelgebirge und am Alpenrand um die
null Grad am Main und auch am Rhein
geht's auf fünf bis sechs Grad drauf und
auch morgen wird eher für die meisten
doch ein drüber Tag hin und wieder ist
es nicht völlig ausgeschlossen dass aus
dieser Wolken Decke mal so ein bisschen
schnee-riese oder eine Schneeflocke oder
etwas Nieselregen herauskommt besser
klappt das mit dem Sonnenschein hier von
der Nordseeküste bis zur Eifel besonders
am Nachmittag der Wind kommt meist aus
nordöstlichen an der Nordsee aus
südwestlichen Richtungen und dieses
Wetter wird uns auch noch am Mittwoch
begleiten am Donnerstag kommen dann
Schnee und Regenwolken von Nordwesten
heran und dann kann es vorübergehend
gefährlich glatt werden guten Abend